hello and welcome to this video playing
mark one cool what is that it's
Indonesia wasn't sure sometimes there
are little things there in those flags
you cannot spot those symbols ok we have
a banco with f3 check let's see what we
get him should be to 193 other usual
moves but surprising that he that he has
to think here in this position or
interesting 92 normally they play night
a three as long as the opportunity is
there ok i think i'll just go back with
the Queen and let's see how he will
develop maybe he will move the bishop
again and then play 92 certainly
possible
[Music]
yeah like that
kind often wipo playing a 83 m no not
not this time maybe wish of age 60 m you
playing that I don't think an h-file
attack looks promising for white he
disagrees and just goes for it so how do
we how do we punish that yeah usually
you want to play in the center so that's
what I do ninety-six knight c6 just
playing for the development that's
probably a good movie on at least better
than many others that were available but
I've got 94 now and I not sure if white
is castling all that easily him a light
squares are a bit vulnerable my kid
sacrifices on g6 f7 and so on could be
on the cards
but okay this age for move is something
that is not and not such such an easy
thing for for--why to handle
yeah so where do we go for potential see
form
Teague and place you for I think I'll do
it it's not be too sophisticated about
it yeah this is not so good check
quite resigned and then that idea had
seen two or three moves ago that there's
always those tactics here when I have c4
Andrew k7 was running right into that
yeah let's let's check this a little bit
of an unusual opening usually white goes
him so that he gets there quickly um I
have never seen 92 in this pollution
yeah maybe what the engine suggests here
the immediate is six is good gem
directly opening it up I was thinking it
cannot help I cannot hurt that he needs
to move the bishop again yeah I think it
it was a fairly normal position age form
I don't know I really don't know you're
not going to checkmate black quickly and
age for is a long-term weakness yeah
he's six I felt was logical pushing for
a media counterplay the computer wants
to play the more normal let's say Bishop
a six probably this is going to happen
and just this position it's certainly
possible yeah I like the idea to open it
up it wasn't all there clear night f1
yeah I think if he grabs it this should
give me pretty nice compensation and I
always have ideas to jump into D 48 who
is also attacked the computer also likes
black in this position here I mean I'm
certainly ok not sure if I'm better rook
85 no that wasn't on my radar I'm just
interested in the position here to see
for Queen deform with roughly quality
air will be 8 yeah that's also a nice
mover controlling this looking at the
pawn yeah
I think 11 long-term issue that white
has here is that the king it's not going
to find a totally safe place anymore now
with all the pawn mercier and special eh
for you don't have a super obvious King
shelter anymore and okay that helped of
course yeah thanks for watching